it's been nine months since apple
released magsafe one of the most
standout features of the iphone 12
and now that we've seen and tested a
bunch of first and third party
accessories
as well as know the full details of
charging performance and efficiency
is magsafe a must-have killer feature in
the future of iphone ipad
that will replace wire charging ports or
is it just a gimmick that should have
been left out in exchange for bigger
batteries and lower prices
well to be honest i think it is both
depending on your use case
in some ways i absolutely love it and i
don't know if i would ever want to go
back to a phone without max 8
but on the other hand it's also
frustrating knowing
how well it could have worked if apple
did it right in this video i will share
my personal experience and thoughts on
where
apple succeeded and where they just
couldn't make it work the way they
wanted to
and how that is going to affect the
iphone 13 and 14
as well as future ipads let's start out
almost a year
ago when the first leaks of apple
including magnets into the iphone 12
popped up
people were really surprised by this and
had a tough time wrapping their minds
around
why apple would want a bunch of magnets
looking like an arc reactor from iron
man taking up space
inside of their phone a few people
mentioned that it could help with lining
up wireless chargers which made some
sense
but ended up being much more than that
two months after that at apple's october
event they showed off the final product
and i have to say i was blown away now
sure the new design and faster and more
reliable 5g antennas were exciting
and i was looking forward to the
upgraded cameras but we all
expected those things that android
phones already had all of that
but this was something completely new
different and really promising they
showed off cases with magnets built in
that easily attached to the iphones
a sleeve with a small cutout on the
display for time
a simple wallet that snapped and stuck
right to your phone
the magsafe duo charger also some
third-party belkan accessories
and of course the magsafe puck charger
we'll also talk about which of these are
amazing
and which ones have been a bit
disappointing right
away vadim made an apple master plan
video about how apple had been planning
this for a while
and how magsafe will be so good that
people are going to want to upgrade for
this reason
and it will keep more people tied into
the ecosystem
so after nine months was vadim right
well right away our first experience was
with apple's case and maxi puck
before the iphone 12s arrived i bought
the clear case which is the only one
where you can actually see the magnets
and started running some tests which is
where i broke my first finding on
maxsafe
that was published all over the internet
first off the new iphone 12 cases cost
10
more than before so to buy a genuine
apple case you now have to spend at
least 49
so it definitely isn't cheap thankfully
we found that the magnetic connection
with the puck was decently strong
and the overall design seemed to be
really nice to perfectly align the
charger
but it's after that video where i
started testing
and found the first flaw in the system
and that was the charging rate
for standard qi devices on apple's mac
safe product page compatibility section
they listed the mac safe can not only
charge iphone 12s
but also iphone 11s 10s and even all the
way back to the iphone 8
as well as airpods and while this is
technically true
maxsafe doesn't seem to be a beefed up
qi charger because
in real world speeds with these older
devices as well as android phones
i found that they only delivered between
one to three watts of charging
instead of the 15 watt max safe rating
or even a 7.5 watt standard
slow wireless charging which we were
expecting that's pretty
slow in fact 7.5 watt wireless charging
is noticeably slower than
even the old 5 watt charging bricks that
took forever so
if you use a magsafe charger for your
iphone 11 pro max
it would take about 12 and a half hours
to charge
compared to two hours with a wired fast
charger
so it's no wonder that cases with max
safe alignment magnets
never caught on for the older iphones it
seemed like magsafe was brand new tech
that might be much more efficient
and my only conclusion was that apple
had to put a separate recoil
or section of the coil for regular qi
but as we move on
you'll see that we now know that that is
not really true
the promise of 15 watt wireless charging
was very
intriguing when apple finally added
wireless charging to their phones they
only allowed 5 watt wireless charging at
first
until it was bumped up to 7.5 watts
where android were
already using 10 and even 15 watt
wireless charging
i personally loved wireless charging and
have used it since they added it but
there's always been those issues with
proper alignment and speed
because it was so slow i only used
wireless charging by my bed for
overnight charging
but with that i was still having issues
waking up and my phone would be
completely dead
most of the time it would still show up
as charging but it wasn't perfectly
aligned
so the charge rate was so slow that it
was still draining
or it would shut off after max safe
alignment has been
amazing for this and my phone is
perfectly charged every morning
max safe alignment has been amazing for
this and my phone is perfectly charged
every morning
and with the puck if you want to lay in
bed and use the same charger you can
unlike most wireless pads as for the
second part
charging speeds i went in depth to see
just how much faster apple's 15 watt
maxi charging was
compared to standard 7.5 watt g charging
charging speeds were definitely faster
especially at lower speeds
but not hitting that double speed as it
would suggest based on the advertised
wattage
and overall it only charged 30 minutes
faster than slow wireless charging
and 15 minutes faster than a 5 watt
charging brick
that's mostly because of how fast apple
tapers down that 15 watts down to 12.5
and then down to just 6 watts pulled
from a 20 watt brick
but even with that the other features of
magsafe made it amazing for me
i am somebody who always wanted a
magnetic car mount which some cases
offered
but then you lost out on wireless
charging which i didn't want to do
plus i really prefer not having a case
making my phone thicker and covering
all of the premium materials maxsafe
allowed both of those to be used
at the same time we ended up buying a
ton of accessories to test and some of
them have been fantastic for me
and many aren't even true max safe and i
don't even mind
here's why one of the first was the
wallet it got a bunch of bad press at
launch but for me it finally allowed me
to keep a slim tidy wallet
because you couldn't overstuff it and i
finally got rid of that big wallet bulge
plus i could keep attached to my phone
if i ever was
just wanting to throw in a jacket or in
one pocket if i needed to carry
something else
i then got the moft wallet which isn't
as
nice or smooth on the back but it is
very flexible since it can hold
one more card and they are much easier
to get out
plus it can be used as a stand as well
the magnum strength was a little bit
weaker though
about that if you use a case it does
help a little bit
but not enough i didn't try the crazy
expensive
sleeve since that seemed like a
nightmare for those who use their phone
often
but the duo charger seemed like an
excellent idea just not a hundred thirty
dollars plus haven't had a twenty dollar
brick excellent
i bought a third party one for much
cheaper and even though the magnets are
weaker and you don't get the official 51
charging speed
i only use this for portable use so all
i have to bring with me is a usb type-c
charger that can handle my macbook and
then this mat to be able to charge my
apple watch and my iphone
this has been awesome just to keep in my
bag at all times because it's so small
and portable
and i typically only use it overnight so
saving 30 minutes of charging time is
negligible
oh and the official one doesn't even
offer full 15 watts
anyways with that for home use i
hesitantly dropped the money on belkin's
three-in-one charger
that is really well made and i don't
regret it one bit
it has been the most reliable and useful
wireless charger that i've ever bought
and it is so convenient to charge all of
my devices
but for those of you guys who are on a
budget we also tested the third party
one
that isn't as well made but it still
works great thanks to those max 8
alignment magnets
and once again the charging speed
difference don't really matter
and in the car i personally use two
chargers
a cheap third-party one that comes with
everything you need in my truck
and a puck holder in our tesla both work
great and hold the iphone without any
issues
and although i thought the much more
expensive official version would be much
better
it's not really and here's why when
apple showed off the insides of the coil
they made it sound very special and new
but in real world use efficiency doesn't
really seem to be that much better
my biggest issue with it is heat and my
phone dimming when i'm using my gps
or even other apps with wireless
charging using the magsafe connection
and even though apple cuts down wattage
very early with magsafe with backsafe
and their coil is supposed to be more
efficient
we don't really see it in the real world
both technologies put out a lot of heat
and the iphone doesn't really deal with
heat very well
because they don't have any cooling tech
built in like android phones
do and that brings us to the magnetic
battery banks
and you guys have probably seen that i
wasn't very happy with
apple's solution while waiting for this
we all expected max safe speeds that
could hit
15 watts even if it was brief but
instead we are limited to 5 watts
just like with regular qi and it's
actually slower than many third-party
options
with that there are also a ton of
limitations on when they will actually
even charge
what this shows us is that apple's
current coil and cooling tech
isn't much better than much older qi
solutions
and now we actually have proof chinese
qi battery packs have an efficiency of a
low
45 percent which is combined from the
losses of wireless charging
and pulling from batteries and apple's
solution is
55 because of this even though apple
makes great looking accessories
in terms of actual performance
third-party solutions can come
close to or even better than what apple
is offering
and with that to answer the question if
this will replace
lightning ports soon i think that apple
is still planning on that but it will
take a lot longer than they hoped
to me the biggest reason why is because
the battery pack was released
nine months after launch of the phones
where most companies would want to
launch it
right away to get the most sales when
people are buying brand new devices with
exciting new tech
they're excited about and then also
during the holidays since
other people can gift those packs to
people that just dropped the money
and can make use of that the way they
release them out of the blue and so much
later makes it seem
like they've been working on it for a
long time and they just couldn't get it
right
and had to settle on slow 5 watt
wireless charging
and just get the thing out there before
the next iphone's
launch most people expected it to be
able to be charged by magsafe either
with two coils or just from the one
but it can't and it obviously has attack
and it unlocks
reverse wireless charging but only on
the iphone 12
and it is insanely slow your main
charging
is from a lightning cable and that
pretty much guarantees
that the upcoming iphone 13 and likely
the iphone 14
are also going to stick with lightning
just like air power
apple has big ambitions for magsafe but
because of thermals and efficiency it
just isn't performing as well as they'd
hoped
which is why power gets limited so much
and so quickly
we do have rumors of a bigger coil in
upcoming iphones
so maybe apple is upgrading that as well
as
stronger magnets which could tackle both
of the biggest issues
let's just hope that efficiency goes up
as well the magnetic alignment tech is
fantastic and i absolutely love it
and we already have copies of it from
chinese brands but those
include a fan to fix the heat issue and
allow for faster charging
but of course apple would never do such
a thing until
apple can fix that even with all of the
efforts they've made
there is no way that wireless charging
can take over wired
and they can get rid of the lightning
port as a supplemental
very convenient charging accessory sure
but apple's tech is nowhere close enough
to make it a primary option
with that although the charging tech is
a bit of a fail compared to advertising
and specs
the magnetic aspect is definitely the
future and i'm excited to see where
apple could take it
in the next few years thank you guys for
watching click that circle above to
subscribe if you guys want to see more
videos like this one
check out one of those ultimate tests
right over there this is max and i will
see you in the next video